whatever helps to get close to you take  a look like anyone but there's only one  of it  they're all looking he care believe me  they're all looking at you know  right good  you and me I know nothing else is good  we were mad she'll leave you what is she  doing shut up James I'm sad dog in you  think that's the strategy that could  work no i don't i don't think this is  strange is yet more hey listen up  everyone i'm extremely sad involuntary  physical response confusion what is  happening to my body it's called dancing  move do not dancing hi kan Dao how long  before this kills me click I am not in  control of my own extremities work i do  not want it to work hey you know what  boo rhymes the groove shake your booth